I want to play a video for you of an
attendee at a turning point USA event
where a woman blames Donald Trump for
millions of vaccine deaths what what how
what is she talking about
she says I'm a DeSantis gal because
Trump led to millions of vaccine deaths
listen to this Trump or DeSantis right
DeSantis all day why well because I
don't like vaccine salesman and uh
millions of people are being killed all
across the world and I blame Donald
Trump for that right
Trump helped develop the vaccines she
believes anyway and therefore Trump is
responsible for the millions of vaccine
deaths around the world you know I think
at this point in January of 2023
if you still believe the coveted
vaccines have killed millions of people
I doubt I can say anything to bring you
back to reality but this has been
floating around for a long time there's
just no evidence that people are dying
from the covid vaccine it's important to
understand that when these folks talk
about the veyers system vaccine adverse
event Reporting System vayers anybody
can submit anything they want to the
vayer system it's not a definitive
source of information on vaccine safety
the submissions to vayers include
anything that happens after vaccination
whether it's related to the vaccine or
not you get a heart attack and die 10
months after getting vaccinated it can
end up in theirs and people like this
woman
we'll say that's a vaccine death theirs
is a passive surveillance system it
relies on people like you or me or a
health care professional to voluntarily
report events that take place it doesn't
capture all Adverse Events it doesn't
link adverse event events to the vaccine
it doesn't do any of those things I even
on a live stream filled out such a
report I didn't hit submit because I
don't want to be part of the fraud but
anybody can just go in and say got the
vaccine and died uh it's not use useful
in figuring out whether people are dying
from the vaccine and when we ask the
question do we have evidence that people
are dying from the coveted vaccine the
answer is no
um you have a combination of lies and
then just correlation that is not
causation in any way car accident nine
months after the vaccine shows up in
vayers what the is that representative
of the spirit of what we're trying to
track it is not
um so unfortunately this stuff is still
around it's continuing to circulate I
don't know that I can single-handedly
shut down the disinformation but the
interesting thing with this particular
woman is DeSantis also said go and get
vaccinated he later backed off and said
well no mandates and not these people in
that and consider that the other thing
but DeSantis was also out there saying
people should get vaccinated I don't
think I can change her I don't think I
can change any of these people but at
some point if we can it's good to
introduce a little bit of reality to
some of these discussions
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below